Чи дійсно Німеччина - найпопулярніша країна
для еміграції в Європі?
Так. Кожен 4-й громадянин має міграційне походження.
Це означає, що якщо взяти середньостатистичну сім'ю з 4 осіб,
то один із батьків, швидше за все,
має міграційне походження.
А якщо порівняти Німеччину з іншими країнами світу
за рівнем міграції, тут ФРН на другому місці.
Беззаперечний лідер - США.
А такі популярні для переїзду країни, як Канада,
Австралія та Швейцарія, - позаду Німеччини.
Чи справді більшість приїжджих - біженці?
Ні. Більшість емігрувала у 2017 році
з Румунії, Польщі та Болгарії. Сирія -
лише на 4-му місці. Головна причина
еміграції східних європейців - пошук роботи.
Але чи всі її знаходять?
Ні. Із 2 мільйонів 300 тисяч безробітних у Німеччині
майже половина мають міграційне походження.
Відсоток безробітних серед них удвічі вищий.
Чому так? Найчастіше - через незнання німецької мови.
Друга причина - дискримінація.
На роботу здебільшого не хочуть брати людей
із турецькими та арабськими іменами.
За даними досліджень, шанси працевлаштуватися
у людини з такою ж кваліфікацією, але
німецьким іменем, набагато вищі.
Чи раді емігрантам у Німеччині? І так, і ні.
52% німців вважають, що приїжджих надто багато,
тоді як 65% бачать у цьому позитивний вплив на економіку.
Чи ускладнює німецький термін
"міграційне походження" життя? Так.
Емігрантів офіційно вважають німцями,
лише починаючи з третього покоління.
Тим часом у таких країнах, як, приміром,
Великобританія або Польща, ярлик "мігрант"
зникає вже у другому поколінні.
Німеччина залишається однією з найпопулярніших
країн для еміграції й серед українців.
Минулого року громадянами Німеччини стали
2,5 тисячі українців. Це менше, ніж у попередні роки,
бо загалом за останні 5 років німецький паспорт
отримали 16,5 тисяч громадян України.
Загалом у ФРН, за офіційними даними, нині
проживають 141 тисяча 350 українців, які
не відмовилися від українського громадянства.
Схоже, мігрантів у Німеччині, зокрема і з України,
найближчим часом побільшає, адже
вже з нового року набуває чинності закон, який
відкриває ринок праці не лише для
висококваліфікованих працівників, але й
представників робітничих професій з країн,
які не входять до Європейського Союзу.
Країні бракує робочих рук, адже
німецьке суспільство старішає,
і працездатних громадян стає дедалі менше.
Фахівці вирахували, що компенсувати нестачу
робочих рук вийде, якщо в Німеччину щорічно
приїжджатимуть 260 тисяч мігрантів.
Переїхати до ФРН для працевлаштування
можна буде лише, підтвердивши свою
професійну освіту в Німеччині, а це може бути
складно і довго. Тобто якщо хочеш працювати
в Німеччині перукарем, то відповідно має бути
диплом перукаря, а якщо слюсарем,
то диплом слюсаря. Іще одна обов’язкова умова -
знання німецької мови. Не обов’язково
володіти нею досконало. Головне -
впевнено розмовляти в межах своєї професії.
Буде скасовано практику перевірки пріоритету,
коли на вакантне місце  пріоритетне право мають
громадяни Німеччини, потім громадяни Євросоюзу,
а вже потім - інших країн. Водночас уряд залишає
за собою право запроваджувати обмеження
по професіях, якщо в тих чи інших галузях
німецької економіки розпочнеться спад.
На пошук роботи даватимуть півроку,
але жити в Німеччині весь цей час
доведеться за свій рахунок.